いいいい
こんばんはメル寸前の端詰雪をです
目が覚めたよ目が覚めたんでしょエグ食べたよね行ってみぐ食べたよ
8疲れてるみたいですね i 邸で今日はですねえ前なのでちょっとゆるーくいき
ましょう私はじめシャツを23歳こんな僕にも歯はいい時期がありました今回の動画で
は僕の子供の頃をどんな子だったのか押すと見ていきましょうどんな風に育って炎よ
ような超点差が生まれたのかなんか写真家の手がかりがあればいいなと思っております
今後もね息子ができたらね僕みたいに店さんいい今で育てたいんで何か参考になれれば
いいなと思っております子供の頃からずっと写真撮られててそれはアルバムにしてるん
ですよねおいであるパパのある部分中で俺があってれると全部奥へんって言ってかあ
ちゃんに送ってもらったんで僕は子どものころどんな子だったのかなんて-1
見ていきましょうはい1枚目は固定です
あ面影はありますが幼稚園保育所可
一度の忘れてやエレクトーンかなピアノ3点のちょっと習ってまして
通算までピアノっぽいのやってました今じゃもう全く弾けないんですけど週1の
レッスンで練習を絶対していかないタイプの生徒だったので毎回鬼のように怒られてて
あんまり楽しくなかったです次
はぁはぁはぁ神の研磨
ある青の丸いぞこの時恐竜博物館に多分応答とといったんですけどこの頃からもう
ちょっと何か
4つが出てたのかもしれないですねつぎまあこれは懐かしいですねこれ中学校の時です
強くの時僕生徒が衣服が5で立候補しまして
俺公約ちゃんと書いてあるのが学習発表会合唱コンクールの成功へ地上生活の見直し
委員会の活性化いい
ピント骨は打ち当選して生徒会副会長になりましたありがとうございます次俺雑でしょ
一つで初手から写真じゃないそれはてるぼく自分で書いたんですよねあの自分で帰った
天気ポスターです
まあこれかわいいですね可愛い可愛い可愛いらしい形の小学校入学式とかですね顔に
ちょっと
っぽをもう鍵がですか
はいらしいです次からなぁで見かけ月てますねをネームだったのかもしれないね
ちょっと頭打ってねちょっとマルイねつぎ
ああはじめちゃんどうすっ車がすごい昔好きだったんですよミニカーとか普段ミニカー
みたいな多分小さいくれますか持たせてられなかったんですけど
持って初めてこういうなんか馬鹿でかいティアのオフロードカーみたいな
車をもらった分テンションあがりすぎてる主にかけてるところにすぎ
これまた可愛いですねプールで遊んでますね3 c にエリア三者別は僕のを頭部に
作ったけどない笑顔で砂次これなんだろこの頃からちょっと中二病を発症させて乗った
のか知らないですけど次これは多分生まれた時ですが
ん
ちゃんってやちょっと待てやアイスクリームがうまく食べれなかったのかなぁ
んな顔でこうやって指差しても全然かっこよくないからねつぎ
ずっと
ちょっと待ってよこの笑顔と剣を持ってるこの仕草
昔と変わってねーなー近くに県があるというと某また恥ずかしいです何かあんまり
目指すと変わってないんだかも死んだよね
方が好きなんですよ刀次これは多分結構最近ですね高校生のときの写真です運動会から
団長をやってたんでちょっと
肝臓がキラキラの衣装を着て走らなきゃいけないっていうんですけども見事に形だけで
てるっていうね顔が若いな
ただのほっこり動画になっちゃったんですけど正山だろうなこれは成長しないなぁと
思いました家族には大事にされてここまで育ったので本当家族にも感謝しております
ありがとうございます
感じですごくの子供の頃以上肇社長の子供の頃の写真
でしたちょっとこっぱずかしい企画だったらまた何か面白い写真やったらカーズに聞い
てみるんでまたひょっとしたら見るかも知れませんじゃなぁ
me
ん
ru ん